what are your most important Platforms
in order obviously it's YouTube at the
top for me why because I'm a long form I
have multiple channels I'm building it
on so we got valuetainment we got
valuetainment Russian that's where our
main driver is Instagram is playing a
very big role right now Facebook is
probably three Tick Tock is good for a
lot of people we were growing very
rapidly on Tick Tock the last time we
had a hundred thousand view was uh 350
videos ago so we don't know what's going
on there so the same Clips we put on
Tick Tock gets 2 000 views but we'll put
it on Instagram and it'll get you know
two million views eight million views
six million views but I would I would
put those would be the list